[Musique]
depuis toujours on nous dit que nos vies
doivent être orchestrée au quart de tour
que chaque minute compte
cuisine express recettes rapides riz
minutes il faut gagner du temps coûte
que coûte
on a de la difficulté à retrouver son
souffle on arrive le soir les gens ont
faim les enfants ont faim dalphond
lorsqu'on un signal très sain de dire
bête mais ça ça tape tout pile c'est
réglé c'est beaucoup pour beaucoup de
consommateurs beaucoup de consommatrices
l'industrie en profite et nous offre une
multitude d'aliments prêts l'avait près
portionné précuits même du poulet ray
coupé comme à laval et pas n'importe
quoi plonger le nouveau poulet précoupés
d'exceldor offert un cube filet
médaillon et la new york
on nous promet plus de temps mais qu'en
est il vraiment l'épicerie a voulu
savoir combien de temps on gagne et
combien ça nous coûte nous avons donc
préparé des repas d'une journée pour une
personne d'abord un bon petit déjeuner
maison avec pamplemousse grue yo yo
gourd aux noix et café et son équivalent
proportionnée pour un pamplemousse en
petit pot de plastique on gagne 2
minutes 12 secondes en temps puisqu'on
n'a pas à le couper les bûchers et le
portionné acheter entier et nous en
coûtera 66,5 pour 90 g de chair versus
de dollars 10,9 pour la même quantité en
petits pots
nous avons calculé un gros 56 secondes
pour préparer notre propre yo gourd
l'ensemble yo gourd et noah nous coûtera
1 dans l'art 90 la portion de 150
grammes
la version maison 76 cents de moins soit
1 dollar 14 le test du sachet de gruau
même quantité d'eau même temps de
cuisson même quantité de gruau
différence et celle ci alors on fait 2-2
tu as encore que ceux ci le tir de danse
même durée autre exemple le café 69,5 en
dosettes ou la même quantité dans un
filtre réutilisables pour seulement 34
seul hong hanh quarante et une secondes
mais on le paie deux fois plus cher
c'est faux tellement que ça prend
beaucoup plus de temps c'est que ça nous
permet de penser qu'on va mettre ce
temps là à autre chose c'est surtout
d'enfants de dire te prends goût de le
faire fait l'époque
ici on a des selleries sont déjà dans
une barquette 8 dollars 86 avouer que
couper le céleri la ville portionné le
mettre dans une petite d'arc est content
de cette power c'est pas toi y'a plus
donc non ça c'est clair
on parle d'un profit moyen brut sur des
produits de base havrais 19/20 pour ça
là on est rendu dans le sang pour sang
ces danses à 150% facilement mais dans
le fond le signal qu'on vous donne c'est
voici une partie qui est pas plaisant
pour vous dans votre journée consacrée
dans votre temps à faire quelque chose
de mieux
nous on va s'occuper de la partie non
plaisante ce qu'on vous dit ce point
évidemment c'est combien on va vous
chargez pour s'occuper de la partie qui
ne vous plait plus notre repas du midi
comprenait entre autres une salade
grecque
accompagné de 2 e un gain de temps de 19
minutes mais la salade vendu 5 dollars
29 a coûté 4 $ de plus que si on l'avait
fait nous mêmes face d eux d eux d
accueil des cultures
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire cuire
mais en plus de ne pas besoin d'aidé et
cahiers parce que le grand risque des
gens encore une fois là dedans c'est
peut-être qu'ils vont être occupés assez
cuit
déjà comparé d'ouvrir un oeuf qui serait
pas assez cuit et c'est fou ce que je
vais dire mais le risque d'erreur est
important maintenant pour les
consommateurs visés des consonnes
interne une tasse à mesurer dehors c'est
comme ma grand mère se servir de ça mais
j'en ai même pas la maison deux exemples
qui étonne un emballage de pommes de
terre vendu avec assaisonnements ou
encore ces galettes de viande hachée au
poivre qui prennent moins d'une minute à
faire alors
galette de boeuf assaisonné au poivre
que l'on parte le chronomètre s'il vous
plaît top chrono
revenons à notre test c'est le souper
fête à la maison qui a nécessité le plus
tant préparation soit 1h18
mais si on retranche le temps de cuisson
des betteraves qui est quand même
considérable le temps total de
préparation et de huit minutes 21
secondes
de plus on ne perd du coup notre
relation avec les aliments avec la
préparation d'aliments
on dirait qu'on fait beaucoup de
recettes qu'on va recevoir des gens mais
pour tous les jours on veut éviter tout
ça puis on achète tout fait
et ce tous fait produit une quantité
considérable d'emballage marlène hodgson
un spécialiste en environnement le
demande le plus c'est vraiment
l'emballage supplémentaire qui est
requis aux aliments pour pouvoir avoir
une durée de vie plus longue des leçons
prend l'exemple d'un pamplemousse qui a
déjà sa protection naturelle une fois
qu'ils aient coupé mais on a besoin de
mettre une nouvelle protection et on a
besoin plus de le réfrigérer pour qu'on
garde sa durée de vie contrairement à un
pamplemousse qui peut rester sur eux sur
la fable est pucé corps et donc c'est
vraiment un impact plus large sur que
l'on voit beaucoup l'emballage mais
l'impact qu'il va plus loin que ça vaut
aussi dans la préparation il vaut dans
la réfrigération et vaud dans l'espace
supplémentaire qu'ils l'espèrent
supplémentaire des tablettes réfrigérée
en supermarché l'espace supplémentaire
dans nos frigos chez nous donc tout ça a
aussi un impact qu'on voit moins faut
toujours penser dans les 3 r le premier
c'est réduction donc réussir à réduire
les quantités d'emballages qu'on fait un
pli coup c'est de faire un peu plus nous
retourne même coupé nauheim en main
selon don exemple on constate que pour
trois repas une personne seule gamme 23
milieu dans sa journée en utilisant du
proportionnée mais hélas 15 $ de moins
dans ses poches
c'est un manque de 105 dollars par
semaine et de 420 dollars par mois
imaginez le coût pour une année
[Musique]